for day 2 of stoic wake 2015 I wanted to
talk a little bit about a work and
author who I am particularly captivated
by there is a lot of Stoicism in this so
it fits in with stowing week but the
author himself is not completely a
snowing although he was quite attracted
to certain aspects of Stoicism
particularly its moral theories its
ethics and the long through that I'm
going to focus on this entire stoic week
is Marcus Tullius Cicero the great Roman
orator lawyer statesman and indeed
philosopher it's through Cicero that we
possess a lot of the information that we
have about quite a few of the figures
and schools of ancient philosophy in
these very important bridge periods you
know much of the works of philosophers
of antiquity even the ones like Plato
and Aristotle we don't possess them in
their entirety when it comes to the
stoics we've lost most of what was
written unfortunately unless you know we
get lucky and happened to come across
you know some archaeological find
somewhere I always hope right the NSO
Cicero was somebody who was fortunate
enough to study with some of the main
representatives the the you know the
cream of the crop of various schools of
philosophy both in Rome and and in
Greece and towards the end of his life
he spent quite a bit of time writing in
part because he wanted to as he put it
take Greek philosophy and put it into
the Latin tongue he thought that it was
important that that in Romans who now
were really at the center of the
civilized world should be able to read
and think about Greek philosophy in the
room language on their own terms not not
just
having to go off to Greece to study not
I'm going to learn Greek and pretending
that certain things can't be translated
there was kind of an elite ISM involved
in that that Cicero really it didn't
like and he thought that the Latin
language was in fact rich enough to
encompass what it was a Greek
philosophers while offering so this is a
particularly important and interesting
work it's like I put here it's a
philosophical dialogue it's actually a
series of dialogues carried out on what
we call five books now for those of you
who are not familiar with ancient
literature when we talk about a book in
terms of Plato or Cicero or Marcus
Aurelius or anybody like that what we
really mean is a scroll we don't mean a
book in the sense of something that we
hold in our hand this is a labellum in
Latin by the way something that the
stoics happen to have popularized this
by the way is the lobe edition which is
the land on one side and the English on
the other side so it's really about
twice as thick as it needs to be in
order to provide the entire thing find
the books or rather five chapters and
each one of them is set up in man so we
get presentations like I put around the
board presentations and then criticisms
the various important ethical systems
late antiquity the ones that were being
provided by philosophical schools the
ones that Cicero thought really needed
to be taken seriously the ones that were
actually making their way into the
intellectual and sometimes even the
popular culture of the time now I'm
among them the two probably most
important ones the two that have the
greatest gripping point in in Roman
culture we're going to have a Kurian and
the stoic schools and sister was not a
fan of that Epicurus or the epicureans
or hedonism in general as you'll find
out if you read this work by the way one
of the reasons i'm shooting this video
is i would love to see people reading
this word
so I'm not going to trying to tell you
everything about it i'm just going to
give you some of the key points and i'm
really going to be concentrating on a
little bit of booktube and a good
portion of book 3 the academic skeptics
the academy of play-doh ended up falling
into a kind of skepticism for for a
while before it made its way back to
plato's old philosophy re understood and
then we also have a platonic and
Aristotelian philosophies well when you
see peripatetic that means Aristotelian
because aristotle like to walk around
petter papa para nothing to walk her out
at all he was talking so you know a lot
of his pupils imitated that it's
actually a good practice keeps the brain
active aerosol didn't quite do it for
that reason but each of these is going
to be considered and it's going to be
considered in terms of conversations
that are happening between people there
will be some Cano exposition
particularly in book 3 work a tone the
representative the stoicism says well
you know do you want me to you know give
you the whole stoic system and sister
who says yes that's a great idea why
don't you do that and then system of
course in book 4 will then go on to
criticize the stoic system so when we
got here is a really cool you know
composition in which cicero himself has
injected himself as a character and he
is carefully considering the different
philosophies that are out there in terms
of the these fundamental questions and
he is getting to have the you know the
philosophy is presented by somebody who
really believes in them somebody who has
studied them somebody who has accepted
them somebody who has lived out that
philosophy so you can't get any any
better exposition than that in my view i
put here you know sort of a reminder
what is the key issue
this work the question about the the
ends when we say the ends you know you
think of well the end physically of this
book is right here that here's an end
and here is a man right we're not doing
but ends in that respect we're talking
about goals about purposes about what
puts everything else into perspective
about priorities if you like and the
question here is what is the highest
good or as they called it the end of
goods you could think of it as a certain
scale of goods and what is the at the
top what is the thing that you should
sacrifice everything else for if you
need to I mean if you think that it's
pleasure like the epicureans did you're
going to live a very different kind of
life than somebody who thinks that is
moral virtue like the Stoics did or who
thinks that its moral virtue but mixed
in with some other stuff like you know
the resilience did or that it's you know
to acquire knowledge whatever it
requires the way the academic skeptics
did and arguably Plato did as well these
are the sorts of fundamental questions
that are never going to grow old and
long after you and I have left this you
know temporary abode of our lives here
on earth you know Milania from now human
beings if they're around are still going
to be asking and still working out
answers to these questions so it's
really worthwhile particularly during
stoic week to see what some of the best
representatives of the Stoics that we
possess and to say about this and we
find that in Cicero support now the last
thing that I need to say if we're
actually going into some of the sections
is that what we're getting here is what
is called middle stoicism it's not the
old stoa which was Zeno the originator
and clam phase and precipitous and then
some of their followers and it's not the
late stoa which are the text that we
actually possess like like Marcus
Aurelius and epictetus and Senate
instead this is the middle period where
we have these these brilliant creative
thinkers like pennant ETA's you know and
and you know other stoics who are
grappling with these schools and arguing
with them and try to make sense of stuff
Cicero himself fits in there because
Cicero he himself like I said is a trap
into stoicism but can't buy into an
entirely he's also attracted to academic
skepticism he also like some things
about Aristotle the one groupie doesn't
like it ah so you have a curious but you
know many people in antiquity to have
that that sort of view so what we're
getting here is a highly developed
stoicism that still knows where it came
from in the old stoa and is from
prefiguring where we're going to see it
later on with figures like Epictetus and
Marcus Aurelius so that is my little
resume of this again I can't suggest
strongly enough that you read this work
I don't necessarily think you should do
during stoic week but it is one of the
works that you should if you want have a
philosophical education you should at
one time during your lifetime read
through and think about
in book one of the days in English
Cicero he has a character who is an
epicurean torquatus present the
epicurean position on the final end
which is mainly that what we should seek
is pleasure a life that is pleasurable
as much as we can as it turns out the
the most pleasurable is being free of
pain worry all those sorts of things not
just a life of physical indulgence in
book 2 Cicero himself is injected as a
character he is criticizing from a stoic
perspective or at least a perspective
influenced by stoicism the epicurean
position as it's been put forward a lot
of his criticisms are quite frankly a
little bit off bays and tendentious it's
an interesting question what's going on
there why is this row making criticisms
that he knows aren't really going to
stick blah at one point in book 2 he
sets out this this fundamental challenge
and it is a two sided challenge you
could say that it's a fundamental
challenge to any sort of hedonistic
point of view any anything that thinks
that ultimately ethics reduces to what's
pleasurable and painful as being you
know the most important considerations
it's also identifying pleasure and the
theories that advance that as the
greatest challenge to virtue or to moral
worth so let's look at what he says and
we're going to spend a little bit of
time with the text will do a little bit
of quotation but main points up here so
Cicero says the Epicureanism it is
really the main rival position he says
that we can dismiss the academics
because the academics are skeptics they
don't really know anything anyway in
part because they say nobody knows
anything they don't they don't have any
positive mode he says Epicurus is a more
troublesome opponent
because he is a combination of two
different sorts of pleasure and because
besides himself his friends there have
been so many later champions of his
theory which somehow or other enlist the
support of that least competent but most
powerful adhering the general public so
sister was saying if you want to have
virtue and you want to have a moral way
of living that's distinctively human
you're always going to be sort of going
against the crowd because the crowd is
going to naturally be attracted to
something that if it's not Epicureanism
per se Epicureanism is rather fine it's
certainly going to be some kind of
hedonism that takes pleasure to be the
ultimate goal for human life so he says
unless we refute these adversaries all
virtue all honor all true merits must be
a ban why well because when you say that
the reason why we should be virtuous the
reason why we should be morally good the
reason why we should you know perform
our duties you know all those sorts of
things that the stoic stressed that's
just because that makes us feel good um
that's always a very slippery slope
because something else will also make us
feel good and usually better and if we
do that sort of reasoning we're probably
not going to end up engaged in virtual
cell virtue for something else as soon
as we find that that's something else
that provides us with more pleasure and
less hassle to get it so it says when
all the other systems have been
discarded there remains a duel in which
the combatants are not myself in
torquatus not not personal individuals
but virtue and pleasure there is a
fundamental fork in the road you might
say and one has to choose this way or
this way you can't have both of them at
the same time the Stoics are rather
uncompromising unlike some of the other
schools who they criticized for this
saying you can't compromise and say
you're going to have it all you're
either going to have to
pursue moral virtue or you're going to
pursue pleasure it's one or the other
this by the way it corresponds in moral
theory very closely to what we call a
day ontological ethics that stresses
duty as the main concept that reveals to
us what is fundamentally good and bad
way that we ought to live the way that
we ought to make our choices and
decisions so you know it's you know it's
going to be either virtue or it's going
to be pleasure what are they up so then
he goes on me says like I put here more
worth and the word that it uses that
we're translating here by more worth is
the latin term ho Nesta it's a word that
we get honest from by the way honesty
originally doesn't just mean telling the
truth it means something that's more
pervasive a way of life that is itself
truthful is straightforward is good is
upright and that's the way that an
estimate is used this is a very common
distinction in ancient philosophy
between you know the good as that which
is pleasurable the good as that which is
useful because it leads to other goods
that we want and the good is
intrinsically good as you know for the
for the ancient Greece the good as such
or the good as that know the lands
translated that quite often by onde está
so Cicero is going on to say if more
work can be shown to actually exist then
the entire system of Epicureanism
collapses the ethical system not
necessarily the physics or anything like
that you what he's saying there is if
you can show that not everything is a
matter of pleasure and pain but there is
some thought some other kind of value
that transcends those then those
considerations of pleasure and pain must
become secondary so he says my own view
is that if I can
seed that will area accordingly I begin
by defining the nature of moral worth
and then I'll deal with with your poison
says so buy more worth we understand
that which is a such a nature that
devoid of all utility it can justly be
commended in for itself apart from any
profit or reward so very long and
somewhat fancy way good I'm saying what
I've got here at the board more worth is
that which is praiseworthy that which we
recognize as being good when we praise
something unless we're being you know
facetious or we're being duplicitous
we're actually saying that something is
good at that's why we praise people what
is praiseworthy apart from any sort of
considerations of pleasure and perform
any considerations of usefulness or
profit or it leading to something else
which we desire when we're saying that
something has more worth we're saying
that it's intrinsically valuable we're
saying that it's good in itself despite
his connections with other things it may
need lead to other things that we we see
as being valuable as well you know being
a good person and doing the right thing
might get you a reward but if there's a
big difference between doing the right
thing because it's the right thing and
doing the right thing for the report the
reward that's a matter of usefulness or
utility that he's talking about there
now the ask how he defines moral worth
or the honesta he says affordable
definition such as i have given made you
something to indicate its nature but
this is more clearly explained by the
general verdict of mankind at large and
by the aims and actions of all persons
of high character this is something
where we don't necessarily have to be
ancient Romans to get it since wrote is
saying that any civilized people are
going to have some people who do the
right thing because it's the right thing
because they recognize it
the right thing and they want to align
their own lives with that that is what
moral worth is and for the Stoics virtue
is closely connected with that because
the virtues are what it will allow us to
to embody and to express and to protect
and to create this moral worth now this
is a few other things that are very
interesting too and I'm not going to go
into great detail about this again I
encourage you to read the work human
rationality and our inclinations show to
us what this moral worth is because it's
not just one single thing it is one
category but it encompasses a lot of
things so just use a few examples here
he says we've been you know we've been
is stowed buy it by nature the gift of
Reason active vigorous intelligence able
to carry out several operations at the
same time with extreme speed and because
of this we have a we have a relish for
our own kind because we're rational we
are sociable creatures we have an
inclination to connect up with other
people not just to nuzzle up against
them the way animals do and heard but to
carry on conversation to get to know
each other of course in a week we often
irritate each other and you know compete
with each other that's not all that
there is he also says here we go Nature
has engendered and mankind the desire of
contemplating truth this is a really
interesting question that doesn't get
deeply explored here why do we want
truth wouldn't we be happier with a
bunch of lies if the truth about things
is often uncomfortable aren't we better
off just being lied to enjoying a
pleasant or the usefulness of that since
we're would say no the Stoics would say
no we had an innate desire for truth
because of the kind of creatures that we
are and that leads us to do the things
that are required in order to be able to
acquire
and understand truth so he goes on it he
talks about you know several different
kinds of moral goodness you know the
virtues fit into that we love truth we
love things that are trustworthy simple
and consistent we tend to hate things
insincere false and deceptive late
cheating perjury malice and injustice
and he says you know we want to develop
our own capacities as rational human
beings that is part of moral worth if
that exists that's not just Volusion let
us know except traction
in book 3 of this this work it is Cato
who is a Roman statesman but also a
stoic philosopher whose living it out
who is talking with Cicero was doing
most of the exposition Cicero has
actually asked him to lay out the
stomach system we're not going to go
into all of that and great detail here
this is more of a teaser for you to try
to get you to read the work but also to
present some of the key doctrines that
were important for these stories and
this is a particularly interesting set
of passages and considerations so you
know the stone is the stoic viewpoint
can begin from a number of different
entry points you might say and love them
is by considering our natural
inclinations as the kind of creatures
that we are as human beings as rational
animals so he starts out by saying it is
the view of those who system I adopt
that immediately upon birth a living
creature feels an attachment for itself
and impulse to preserve itself into feel
affection for its own constitution and
for those things which tend to preserve
that Constitution what do you mean is
there is that when we're born and
afterwards though we're not very good at
this is human pigs of course they've a
lot of ways almost killing themselves
living creatures are attached to their
own existence they want to continue in
existence that's part of what it means
to be a lot and they naturally want to
do the sorts of things that are going to
continue anything to augment their
existence and they're going to be
naturally averse towards the things that
detract from their existence the things
that are incompatible with their
existence that threaten it and they're
going to feel positively towards things
which augment their existence or which
wich aid their existence they're going
to feel negative
they're going to be averse of things
that are against that because they have
this desire to continue in there be a
it's like it says it you know this also
means that we have self-consciousness we
feel affection for ourselves and this
leads to the conclusion is love self
which supplies the primary impulse to
action much of what we do is motivated
by this desire ultimately not
necessarily in the immediate sense of
continuing our being and augmenting our
being it's not selfishness this love of
self in the sense of saying you know
it's me against everybody else that's
not necessarily the way it has to be
there may be situations in which that
becomes the case for the stoic but the
stoic doesn't make that as immediate
assumption there's another aspect that's
very important as well he says acts of
cognition which we made term
comprehensions or perceptions or if you
like the greek term kind of late takes
literally grasping something you know we
have getting hold of the world when
we're thinking we're grasping in
thoughts in the distinctive with human
beings our environment and we also turn
our thought in upon ourselves and what
we're feeling today and what we want to
do later on and what we think about that
all of these are things that we do as
human beings as part of our natures is
acts of cognition these we consider me
to be adopted for their own sake because
they possess an element that so to speak
embraces and contains the truth in
thinking we actually learn or enact our
desire for truth which Cicero and stoics
Cato to thinks is intrinsic to human
beings this doesn't mean that we always
desire the most truthful solution we can
be misled into other things we can be
pended astray we can even become you
know deceitful people and live out a lie
as we say but that requires some the
bitumen take place there have to be some
some things going wrong in consistent
ways for that to become what grips us so
we desire truth and we reverse the
falsity this is something again which is
sort of natural to us now what's the
upshot of this he says here we go all of
this tells us that it's it's a not
desire that is actually steering us
there we go 77 pleasure rather he says
pleasure it is not to be reckoned among
the primary objects of natural impulse
I'm very strongly agree with them for
fear lest many a moral consequences
would follow if we held that nature's
place pleasure among the earliest
objects of desire we do in fact desire
pleasure that is part of our animal
nature and perhaps even part of our
human nature since we devised all sorts
of pleasures for ourselves that the
animals no understanding up and probably
are better off not from stoy perspective
not dirt but our desire is not
fundamentally about a pleasure it's
about our preserving our own being and
what is appropriate to our are being
what conduces to it and it's about truth
and being a verse to falsity and gaining
more and more truth to understand things
what this means is that we're not just
pleasure desiring animals we're not just
hedonistic alee driven there's more to
life than and since there is more life
than that we should prioritize that more
he says so what does this lead to
ethically says what is in accordance
with me
sure our nature our fully developed
nature as human beings is what is
valuable it has positive value it's when
it calls choice worthy what goes against
that nature is worthy of being chosen
against you might say in estimate you
know in estimable if we want to use the
Latinate version because estimable a is
the latin that he's using here it's
something that we we should choose
against so what is what is going to
fulfill our nature as rational beings as
living beings as rational beings what is
going to lead us to goodness what is
going to lead us to truth we should
pursue that if pleasure is going to
interfere with that pleasure is going to
get in the way we should choose against
pleasure even though pleasure is
something we feel desired towards
because we should desire something
greater than mere pleasure he goes on
and he says there we go that which is an
insult in accordance with nature
produces something that else that is so
in which therefore is deserving a choice
is valuable that's that's what we have
to take as our criterion has our clues
and they says the initial principle
being thus established that things take
in accordance with nature are things to
be taken things to be pursued things to
be chosen for their own sake in their
opposite similar things to be rejected
the first appropriate act and so using
appropriate act of the translation there
another way of translating that is duty
sister was actually going to write a
whole book on duties you know Vicky um
ficm is the singular for it or is a
greedy as caffeic oh that's a term that
the dogs used it literally means in
accordance with what is appropriate
right so these are things that follow
from understanding
the nature of human beings and our
innate desires so he says there we go
the first appropriate act is to preserve
oneself and one's natural Constitution
we have a duty we not only have a desire
we have a duty to preserve ourselves in
our natural Constitution now that
doesn't mean just staying alive that
means not going out and getting so drunk
that you ruin your liver that means not
going and you know engaging in risky
behavior because that's no putting your
your Constitution your life your your
existence at risk it would also means
doing things that are necessary for
continuing your existence you know
you're not going to find Stoics saying
that you shouldn't hold down a job if
you need a job in order to live right so
some people may see this dogs a little
bit too bourgeois for them I tend to
think of it as a good thing he goes on
and he says the next is to retain those
things which are in accordance with
nature and to repeal those that are the
contrary we have duties to do those
things as well then with this principle
of choice and also a rejection has been
discovered there follow next and order
choice conditioned by appropriate action
then such choice that over time becomes
a fixed habit finally choice fully
rationalize and in harmony with nature
he says it's at the final stage that the
good properly so called first emerges
and comes to be understood in its true
nature so it's only when we actually
engage in these appropriate actions that
I do have inclinations telling us remedy
but we also have all sorts of
temptations leading us astray and we can
also get mixed up about this it's when
we engage in these habitual over and
over again and develop a habit that we
can fully understand what the good is
and this points on a really interesting
issue can you convince somebody to
become a stoic overnight probably now if
Cicero and if Cato are right one has to
keep engaging in this over and over
again there will be some people who you
explain this to and they need is it yes
that makes perfect sense that's probably
because they've already been engaged in
this process because of the way that
they were erased or the institution that
they've been working in or were formed
by and that's a good thing from the
stoic perspective he says man's first
attraction was towards the things in
accordance of nature but as soon as he
has understanding or rather becomes
capable of conception as discerning the
order and so to speak harmony that
governs conduct he thereupon esteemed
this harmony far more highly than all
the things for which he originally felt
affection and by exercise of
intelligence and reason and furs the
conclusion that herein lies the chief
good a man the thing that is
praiseworthy a desirable for its own
sake and that is what were you ought to
to see so we we can't find the final end
without engaging and he might say in an
experiment the experiment of using our
life our choice to determine ourselves
in such a way as to be able to grasp
what is what is best for us and if we
can't immediately see it that's probably
a sign that we're not near where we need
to be we got started across the hill yet
so these are all some really interesting
considerations to keep in mind
in book three key also provides an
exposition one of the famous doctrines
of Stoicism about the indifference and
the preferred and the rejected and so
let's take a look at what he's actually
talking about there in these passages
you know I've titled this the good the
bad and the indifferent although it's
going to turn out the indifferent isn't
completely indifferent if it was that
the Stoics would be in a real problem as
we can see so what is good well you know
virtue is good moral value the lunesta
is good living in accordance with nature
those are good those REO since we're
talking about the end the final end
those are expressions of the end of the
best life of the way human beings would
do the best to live what will most of
Phyllis by contrast vice moral dis value
the you know turbat as opposed to the
horn s them and living in contradiction
with major living in such ways that even
though it may come natural to us we're
out of sync with the rest of our
environment were in turmoil within
ourselves that's bad those are the
fundamental goods and bads that
everything else is centered around those
are the poles and then the stoics are
very famous for saying what everything
else in between is indifferent health
well your appearance all those sorts of
things that you don't have control over
that are really not that important you
shouldn't you should be putting your
your focus here on pursuing this and
here on avoiding this and don't worry so
much about the stuff that's more trivial
that's not quite so important now that
raises a big problem right because
stoics also talked quite a bit about
doing the right thing to do right how do
you actually express this how does it
connect up with the rest of the world so
he says we have to make an
the difference between things for if we
maintain that all things were absolutely
indifferent the whole of life would be
thrown into confusion and no function
err task could be found for wisdom there
would be no distinction between things
that pertain to the conduct of life and
no choice need be exercised among them
but we do have to make choices right we
have to make choices all the time
between competing desirable goods or you
know things that present themselves to
us as evils so he says accordingly the
Stoics went on to affirm that among
those things which are of no importance
to happiness or misery there was
nevertheless an element of difference
making some of them positive and some of
them of negative value in others truly
neutral among things valuable among
things that are you know estimable yeah
in the latin are things like health
unimpaired sense its freedom from pain
Fame wealth and the like so they said
that some important adequate grounds for
preferring to other things others are
note of this nature and similarly among
those things which are a negative value
some before an adequate grounds for
rejecting them like pain disease loss of
the senses poverty disgrace others not
so and so we have a distinction here
between the prefer that pro make the
pro-am aha in the Greek and the rejected
the Apple literally away from pro a game
enough in the degree as well so things
that are neutral are in fact neutral in
one sense but they're also not neutral
totally if you if you have to sacrifice
some of those things like for example
let's look at some of them that he
talked about health if you have to say
myself to virtue virtue wins out it's a
you know it's not going to happen all
that often I hope but you know well Fame
those sorts of things the Stoics are not
saying those are awful those are bad
things avoid being famous they're not
naysayers
life but they're saying look favor quite
often is going to entangle you with
things they're going to get you out of
you know sync with the rest of the world
that and place you into competition and
bring out your worst side and keep you
from actually cultivating the best
things and fame can be you know
something to be rejected in some cases
here's the thing to these things that
are preferred interjected their relative
to the two final ends the end of good at
the end of that so he gives an example
here he says in a royal court no one
speaks at the king himself has promoted
to honor right but the term is applied
to those willing some office estate who
drank most nearly approaches though it's
second to the royal preeminence
similarly in the conduct of life the
title pro a Amen on that is promoted is
to be given not to those things which
are in the first ring but to those which
hold the second place Sammy place things
are still important and here's where the
real upshot of this is a little bit
later on he talks about duties again
affiky says although he pronounced moral
worth the own ask them to be the sole
grew it is nevertheless consistent to
perform an appropriate act in spite of
the fact that we count appropriate
action neither good nor an evil for the
sphere of neutral things there is an
element of reasonableness the things
that are preferred are reasonable they
are rational our duties are things to be
preferred by us we don't do duty solely
for its own sake because we love duty
and that's all we're about and turn and
turn ourselves into some sort of you
know weird guilt driven obsessive types
that's not the point of it the point is
to enjoy happiness to enjoy the full
development of human rationality and
human existence and fulfilling our
duties is a necessary component in doing
that in realizing that so he says in the
sphere of these neutral things there is
an element of reasonable
in the sense that an account can be
rendered of it and therefore in the
sense that an account can also be
rendered of an act reasonably performed
now an appropriate active duty in a fit
yet is an axial perform that a
reasonable account can be rendered of
its performance this proves an
appropriate app is an intermediate thing
to be reckoned neither is a good nor is
the opposite so why should we perform
our duties that well because that's the
rational thing to do if we want to live
in accordance with nature more and more
although he doesn't talk about this at
this point think about what I talked
about just a little bit earlier that was
in there that this involves the
reconfiguration of HAP's the building of
our structure of our motivations of our
choices of our what we later out of call
the will which is really what is most
who we are from the stoic perspective
this in Greek crow a racist our Comment
of choices that we make that is really
at the core of the person and carrying
out these duties being able to recognize
what really is a duty what isn't a duty
and when they're to be preferred to each
other to carry up good practical
reasoning that is at the core of the
stomach life